I feel very close to them first of all
you know virtually every Irish person
has a connection with the US whatever
whatever it might be in the case of many
Catholics for example you know a
connection that went back in many cases
to the famine or the succession of
famines in the first part of the 19th
century the 1830s and of course into the
1840s predominantly 1847 and of course
many people those who didn't die many
many of them left the country at that
time so that's one one component of the
of the emigration to this country but
there have been others for example one
I'm particularly interested in is the
great Scotch Irish predominantly
Presbyterian shift these were descent
people who've started and Presbyterians
who came from Scotland in say the late
17th century mid to late 17th century
spent roughly speaking a hundred years
in Northern Ireland find themselves
coming under some impression they're
actually also and then moving on to to
this part of the world in the roughly
let's say the first half of the 18th
century the early 1700s 1840s and they
of course have a huge impact on this
country also a huge impact and you know
some of it perhaps a little troubling in
its way I mean I'm think that in many
cases they were at the forefront of the
the genocide of the native peoples not
something we
want to think about in this country too
much but they were also I mean in that
sense they were they were making making
the country that wouldn't be destroying
another country but that we're making
some version of this one I guess and I'm
always taken aback slightly when I
walked on the Main Street of Princeton
New Jersey where I live and it's called
Nassau Street and it's a Street of
course that's named after Prince William
of Orange and Nassau who was not
necessarily one of our great heroes at
and on my side of the house as it were
back home since it was he himself who
you know overcame James at the Opera
manned the Boyne and the great defeats
of the Catholic armies but there he is
and that that town was named after him
when he was Prince William Prince time
and there the University as a strong
presbyterian background unless to the
fore and I but it was it was set up by
Presbyterians and indeed one of the
presidents of Princeton and the early to
mid 19th century
James macaque came from what was my old
university in Belfast it was then known
as Queens College Queen's University
Belfast it became Queens College and
James Micajah been the professor of
ethics and metaphysics there before
coming over to be President of Princeton
so lots of connections the canal in near
which I live in New Jersey the Delaware
and Raritan canal dug by Irish
navigational Canal workers Irish navvies
so probably speaking Irish singing their
songs and Irish so everywhere everywhere
some sense of that connection and I must
say I mean one of the great things about
this country I believe is that it was so
welcoming to us and and
just so many others and one would like
to think that that it will continue to
be one of its glories
you